got sucks versus mobley  all right we got it programmed we've got  the clocks working game clock says ten  but that doesn't matter at all and the  jump ball won by miami  [Applause]  next score win looks like a clear out  for strews yeah it's a clear out there's  [Applause]  why not max drews have yourself a ball  game  [Applause]  no special plays no secret sauce just a  straight clear out  i ain't seen one for a flat call in the  nba game in a long time  an 11 second  double overtime max streuse it's pure  and he knew it right away too  and that was miami's largest lead of the  game they win it 97 to 94. there goes my  god memphis grizzlies got my guy karan  butler walking over here to congratulate  me  i'm congratulat